cherish the day is on Oprah's network
and have y'all met Oprah before you know
I met her a long time ago the first
movie I did was precious and she was
producer on that so I like met her in
that mix but for cherish we haven't
officially met her yeah but she was at
me it was officially she was at the
table I'm so excited because we walked
in and we were both nervous because
we're you know it's everybody it's a
table read and this is the point where
you can either keep the job when they
fire you but this is how we were like we
got to do our thing and we walk in and
we see her on this big television oh
she's somewhere else she's got Vanessa
skyping in what she's Oprah she got a
lot doing right and she looks you know
she's got glasses on she's ready she's
got her notes she's starting to write
things down and were like is this just
the video and then right well we knew it
was real because when I first walked on
she wasn't on the screen but there was
like okay resort but Oprah story the
first time I met her was just doing her
show because of doing press for seven
pounds with my good story I think is
being at Critics Choice Awards with my
mom sitting next to comment who was like
your mom looking good I was like yes she
is and she was like excuse me come in
Oprah's over there so we like went over
to Oprah's table and then she got Ava
Duvernay to take our photo I was like
she was like it's Oprah I was like okay
so then I took a photo and my mom cuz
I'm working on Ava's new show and my mom
goes ask Ava to ask Oprah for the photo
that we took all those years ago why
would she have she goes no don't you
remember
Oprah took it on her blackberry I'm like
no she didn't take it on her blackberry
why we should do that she's like me you
just need to ask Ava I told it to Ava it
was like I'll find the photo if it was
like not know
No we'll try to take a new one well I'll
take once again yeah yes
so tell thank you dreams check I will
not stop talking until you subscribe to
my youtube channel that's right and I
could talk a lot seriously not gonna
stop yep still here not going anywhere I
see you don't walk away from this